all right also developing tonight
republican congressman ken buck
he is calling for a special counsel now
to investigate
yep we started this uh story in our
coverage in
2018. peter schweitzer writes the
best-selling book
secret empires talks all about zero
experience hunter biden
all the nefarious overseas dealings the
explosive emails
of course released in october those were
the ones of
that the big tech companies were
preventing people from
actually reading all tied to all things
biden
ron johnson senate committee uncovering
hunter biden caught
taking in millions from america's
adversaries
all while his father is vp by the way
imagine if the name was donald trump jr
or eric
trump or ivanka trump if any of them did
it
it would be non-stop never-ending mob
media coverage 24-7 on a loop so
we can begin in 2013 as peter schweitzer
had pointed out in his 2018
book secret empires that's when hunter
zero experience flew with his dad
aboard air force two on that trip to
china
ten days later inks a billion later to
become a 1.5
uh billion dollar sweetheart deal with
the chinese state
uh backed investment fund the bank of
china well we haven't been able to find
any experience or qualifications there
and then of course we learn from ron
johnson and chuck grassley that
because hunter biden opened up a joint
account with the chinese national
connected to china's communist party
that same bank account would fund a
family shopping spree for hunter and his
family
in february of 2014 zero experience
hunter
he got a whopping 3.5 billion billion
million dollar wire
transfer from a corrupt russian oligarch
the wife of the ex-mayor of moscow known
as the first lady of moscow
and again play our little game replace
the name hunter
biden with donald trump jr or any trump
kid
and what do you have you think the
democrats the mob the media big tech
they would censor not report put the
put the trumps in the campaign
protection program
and it wasn't just china wasn't just
russia remember in april of 2014 we now
know according to johnson grassley their
report
kazakh oligarch kazakhstan wired over
140 grand
yep to hunter biden's firm what was it
earmarked for
a brand new pretty darn expensive car
hunter zero experience in kazakhstan
and then it was only a few days later in
may of 2014
zero experience hunter began receiving
massive monthly payouts
from ukrainian energy company barista
holdings
the company was owned by a pro-russian
government oligarch once again
hunter no experience in ukraine no
experience in oil
energy gas but gets paid millions of
dollars goes on good
you have any experience no why do you
think you got it i don't know
maybe because your dad's in charge of
ukrainian money and ukrainian policy
is at the time joe biden was obama's
point man on all things ukraine
we have overwhelming evidence that biden
has been lying all along
well aware of his son's dealings for
example the emails sent from a ukrainian
executive in
april of 2015 thanking zero experience
hunter
for the quote opportunity to meet your
father
and of course biden himself bragging on
tape
about well you got six hours uh
fire the prosecutor or you're not
getting a billion taxpayer dollars
that would be a quid and a pro and a
quote by joe
uh so that prosecutor who was
investigating hunter and barisma
he got fired six hours later son of a
bee they did it
so now the call for this investigation
into the corrupt biden business bureau
well it's way past time for real
accountability it is time for real
answers about
just how much joe biden was willing to
sell access
to the vice presidency and his son and
his family
cashed in big time here with more
republican congressman jim jordan
and congressman ken buck ken let's talk
about what you're fighting for and
asking for here
absolutely sean what i'm asking for is
the attorney general of the united
states to appoint a special counsel to
look into the very facts that you just
pointed out
there is a serious pattern of corruption
that uh hunter biden has engaged in with
joe biden's knowledge
it was just two days after a bureasma
board member met with joe biden that
hunter biden goes on the board of
burisma
and gets 83 000 a month in in payments
it's just 12 days after hunter biden is
on a plane
uh with his dad air force two going to
china
that all of a sudden this uh investment
company is created
there is this pattern of behavior if the
vice president united states is willing
to do it there's no reason to believe
that the president united states won't
do the same thing
all right jim jordan you know i'm going
to tell you how people feel
and when i talk to people with the
telling me is there anything we reported
on the the trump russia 2016
collusion hoax that was wrong anything
about the dirty dossier that we reported
that was wrong anything about
premeditated fraud on the fisa
court that was wrong any of that wrong
no only thing we were wrong about sean
it was worse than we thought and
the way you framed it up is exactly why
ken's call for a special counsel
is needed for four years the democrats
said president trump colluded with
russia we know
that wasn't true they went after his
family deposed don jr for over 30 hours
turns out that whole time it was
actually the biden family who was
enriching themselves
with foreign deals and oh what did we
learn today
today the very people though who accused
him of that over four years
we learned today we're cozying up with
the chinese spy for goodness sake
so of course we need what ken called for
to get to the bottom of this
okay i agree with what ken called for
you were there
durham's been out there after the
horowitz report corroborated everything
you had said and i had said in our
ensemble cast here it said
where's dorm where are the indictments
why didn't anything happen is anything
going to happen sean i don't know and it
is as frustrating for me as
in you and for but more importantly for
the whole country let's hope so
uh again last week the attorney general
told us he is now given the designation
of special counsel to mr durham
let's hope he does the same thing for
what ken is calling for in the biden
hunter biden issue
but we'll have to wait and see i remind
people all the time all we can do is
draw attention to the facts and you've
done that for four years we've done that
ken's done that
but at some point it's the justice
department who actually has to do the
investigations and if the indictments
are warranted
they have to proceed in that manner ken
are you getting any indication because
you're right
on the facts on the merits and we both
we all know all three of us know
and if the last name was trump we'd be
have a very different reaction in the
media
different reaction from democrats
different reaction from big tech
companies they wouldn't be censoring it
but that's i guess is what the corrupt
world we just have to accept now exists
well uh sean i think this story and the
story that you just uh
dealt with with with rana and and dave
and corey
are related uh our great leader on the
on the judiciary committee jim jordan
as the ranking member has been asking
for investigations into this
issue uh in congress and they haven't
come up and if we don't win the senate
um uh if we lose georgia we won't get uh
that that backstop that we need so badly
so i implore the people of georgia to
make sure that they vote
what do you say to georgia we have 20
seconds oh yeah get out there and vote
for
for our senators mr purdue and ms
loffler we got to win those seats and to
to preserve the legacy the great the
great work that president trump has done
in his first term
all right we're not going to stop by the
way when we